un spectacle qui assure le succès d'un
disque c'est un phénomène relativement
fréquents dans ce que l'on appelle le
show business
en revanche il est plus rare qu'un
disque soit à l'origine d'un spectacle
et c'est pourtant ce qui va se produire
avec la représentation de starmania
il s'agit d'un opéra rock francophone
parce que franco québécois le disque a
été vendu à plusieurs millions
d'exemplaires et à partir de ce soir 70
chanteurs musiciens et danseurs
interpréteront ce spectacle dont la mise
en scène est signée tom organes il avait
déjà travaillé sur deux grands
spectacles musicaux air et jesus christ
superstar
l'affiché est exceptionnel france gall
diane dufresne fabienne thibeault
nanette workman et daniel balavoine
seront sur scène en matière de spectacle
ce sera l'un des événements de l'année
patrice drevet le narrateur du spectacle
chez vous c'est l'heure du journal
télévisé chasse est ouverte à naître il
ya c'est le narrateur officiel du
spectacle
georget
le dernier
il est
non
comment
tout le reste est accessoire pour
hippolyte c'est que ce point de vue des
gens font de meetic sur le point de vue
des gens de la rue tout le monde les des
stars star va mieux de pas vers un
cartel le canard cet écart et tu n'auras
python
pour tous adhérents de rocard a jusqu'à
c'est pour ça qu'on a les minutes
étaient quand même quelques stars
ensemble enfin stars sont parmi les
étoiles
les stars de starmania
fabienne thibeault diane dufresne france
gall
nanette workman daniel balavoine
on doit voir ça d'une façon très cartoon
je dire des bandes dessinées alors c'est
le monde aujourd'hui dans une bande
dessinée qui s est enfin de voir ce bon
c'est qu' à qui on doit s'adresser avec
chaussettes starmania se montrent
positifs c'était le mon discours est
plus que tout il a une image de ce fait
font pour le monde qui nous remerciera
bientôt avec des bonds assurons d'abord
de la planche celui pour l'autre sinon
lors de la dernière chance je suis comme
accident rang de la dernière chance
stand confiture
est ce une étoile du futur au calme
absolu
sept chauffeurs l'azur pour moi c'est un
défi d'abord des crises spectacle
françois petit complètement universal
série absolument rien de québécois n'est
rien non plus d'articles
aucun parisien et ce mot aucune
expression sur tout le spectacle était
qu'il en vain français que n'importe
quel francophone du monde peut
comprendre de la première ligne dernier
qu'est ce que je vais faire demain
c'est ce que je me dis tous les matins
1981 est une date très particulière de
l'histoire avec des choses dans le monde
qui sont très spécial quand on quand on
écoute le journal télévisé ou quand on
vit dans le monde intel en vie il ya
vraiment des marques très particulier à
ce monde là et nous on a une trentaine
d'années on a voulu exprimer ce qu'on
voit être comme comme on le ressent
après un spectacle musique
et je vous embrasse xavi et ricains et
et or
collez vous voir la mort enfin
s elle s'habille en technique au sein